if you've ever so much as installed a
competitive first-person shooter
there is one question that you will
never stop asking yourself
what [ __ ] sensitivity should i play
on
from cracked high sense kitties to og
low sends arm aiming
counter strike aficionados this might
just be
the single most hopelessly unanswerable
question
in gaming for some players it's what
haunts them every single time they hop
into the server
causing them to smash the escape key
every time they lose a gunfight
so what is the so-called godsense
[Applause]
you've probably heard of inhuman
reactions
right garrett is going to be waiting
hiko charges in dust and check
oh my god inhuman reactions
well i think it's pretty fair to say
that that one in a million play
never would have happened if hiko played
on a low
sensitivity and it's for that reason
that i am going to explore the
intricacies of sensitivity with you
and why it matters and also why whenever
you talk
to cs go siege overwatch
valorant hell even fortnite players they
won't [ __ ] shut up about it but in
valor and specifically we've seen
players weaken
and week out dominating on insanely high
sensitivities in the server
and there's nothing better than watching
these high sensitivity nut cases
hit these nasty ass shots but are they
just doing it for the looks
or does playing on a higher sensitivity
actually give you an advantage
going all the way back to the origins of
multiplayer fps
such as in quake and eventually
counter-strike finding the right
sensitivity has always been a
constant battle for players now your
sensitivity is made up of
two factors first there is your raw dpi
or just the dpi of your mouse
second there is your in-game sensitivity
dpi or if you want to get technical dots
per inch is a number that can be changed
in your mouse settings to adjust the
speed of your cursor
all right that's a bit of an
oversimplification but
don't worry demetri i got you dots per
inch
or more accurately counts per inch is a
representation of
how many pixels your cursor will move on
screen
when your mouse's sensor registers one
inch of physical movement
while gaming mice can tell some pretty
wild dpi numbers
using a very high dpi can actually start
to create
noise that decreases the accuracy of
your sensor
so running at 12 000 dpi
may not be the best bet now obviously
this is gonna vary from mouse to mouse
so
your mileage may vary all right i hope
you don't mind me inserting myself into
your video dimitri is golden allowed to
just insert himself into my videos like
that
into my videos like that into my videos
like that nah dude it's fine i mean
you're a
filthy casual who uses a controller but
uh
tell me more about how my mouse works
anyway 400
800 and occasionally 1600 are pretty
common dpi values
but none of this really matters because
no matter what
shooter you're testing your metal in
your so-called raw dpi
is always filtered through an in-game
multiplier
usually actuated by a numerical value a
slider
or both now once you find a good
combination of raw and
in-game dpi you'll be able to calculate
your effective dpi
often referred to as e-dpi for csgo
all you have to do is multiply your raw
dpi
by the in-game numerical value according
to pro settings.net
the average cs go competitor has an edpi
of roughly 984
now not every game has a true one-to-one
multiplier like cs
but for the sake of this video we have
already gone ahead and calculated all of
the sensitivities you'll see to their
true edpi of course pro players have
traditionally gravitated towards playing
on a lower sense
because it allows you to be more precise
with your aim whereas
raising your sense gives you an obvious
speed advantage
you'll be able to clear corners much
faster when entering a site
so when a pro player or even you silver
scrubs at home
are making decisions about their
sensitivity that's the trade-off they're
making
precision versus speed but when you're
first
inducted into the tactical fps genre you
should probably start with
low sends and arm aiming this is going
to teach you to lock that crosshair at
head height and allow your opposition to
walk into it
and then it's really just as simple as
clicking their heads and
for years this low sense long movement
playstyle has been the working man's
approach to aiming
even at the esports level the idea being
that you shouldn't really need to focus
on anything outside of your 180 degree
purview
since if the enemy is behind you well
you're already dead
that said low sends isn't always ideal
not all fps games are created equally
good luck
shooting a pharah out of the sky in
overwatch and then
killing a tracer blinking across the map
while you're playing
widowmaker on say 600 edpi
which brings me to high sensitivity the
ultimate
calculated risk as technology has gotten
better and
kids have gotten progressively more
cracked
some very talented players have refined
their ability to maintain
the stability necessary to be precise
in-game
while also increasing their sensitivity
to hit those
nasty flicks and speed their gameplay up
even i who a couple of weeks ago decided
to copy
shroud's sensitivity for shits and gigs
which is
for context about 300 edpi higher than
my own
was able to produce some pretty nutty
[Music]
clips
[Music]
fun fact i posted it to twitter and
watched as my close personal friend get
right
slid into the comments and asked me to
send him
my config so i'm just gonna quietly go
retire now
and while over the course of the last
few years the average sensitivity of pro
players
does seem to actually have gone down
just a little bit because
you know back in the day when they
started out they didn't have
[ __ ] desk mats a select few players
have been able to reach the top of their
games while playing at a
high sense and it kind of makes sense
right you can't be cranking 90s on low
sends and expect
to beat these kids so in some games like
fortnite or call of duty
you're sometimes forced to play at a
higher sense
but when you're shooting the endless
gadgets in rainbow six siege or holding
precise pixel angles
both high and low sends have their
benefits
the choice is the aforementioned
trade-off between precision
and speed and one of the biggest factors
that goes into making that decision
is the role that you play for your team
in siege specifically i guess you could
use this argument for like both high and
low sense is there's just
so many angles you need to look at and
so many like possible pixels and
positions that it could be so i guess
you know if you're maybe an entry
fragger or someone
who is just getting in the middle of
these like angles
you want to have that high sensitivity
to be able to look at everything really
quickly
but then i could also say on the other
end you know when you have like a lower
sense it's easier to really line up
those pixels and line up
you know all these like really like nerd
angles that people could probably
have from across the map all right now
that we understand the pros and cons of
both low and high sensitivity
let's talk about why we're here if the
collective
average dpi of pro players has been kind
of lowering over the last couple of
years
then why is it that we still have these
select few high
sense superstars who were just able to
smurf on people
valorant for instance is still very much
in its infancy
players are still solving the riddles of
these new rifles
but one thing is certain many of the
game's top pros prefer
higher sensitivities than one might
expect given the historical shift
towards low sends especially in
counter-strike
players like tens hiko and asuna are all
twitch clip machines because of their
nutty ass flicks
but how is it that they're able to be so
successful in a game where the gun play
most closely resembles counter-strike
well valrant's unique agent abilities
offer a verticality that was never
present in counter-strike
in cs with some exceptions you can
mostly expect the other team's feet to
be on the ground but in valorant you've
got
jets flying above your head or omens
teleporting behind you
and you need to be on your toes at all
times to be successful
the organized chaos that these abilities
create
is perhaps the reason we've seen former
overwatch pros like
baby bay and corey prove many people
wrong
and actually find success in this
counter-strike inspired shooter
overwatch features even more extreme
verticality
and each hero has different sized health
bars meaning the time to kill
is different for every character but
valorant doesn't have this problem as
baby bay so elegantly observed when i
come to this game it's just like
oh my god like i'm i'm using an op and i
don't have to shoot them in the head i
can just shoot them in the body once and
they're dead like
come on dude you know like i'm sitting
here shooting roadhogs like five times
in the head to kill them as widow it's
like
so so annoying now since nearly all of
faze clan's valorent roster hails from
overwatch
you'd expect them all to play on a
higher sensitivity
but that's not the case in fact
valerian's
shining example of a high sense
superstar
is actually one of the former cs players
who jumped ship when the game came out
100 thieves star player asuna plays on a
whopping 1313 edpi
and just to give you some context
according to prosettings.net the average
valorent competitor plays somewhere in
the arena of a
thousand edpi what asuna is doing is
pretty out of the ordinary but why does
he choose to play on such a high
sensitivity
i mean the pro high sense is just like
you can clear a lot more things quicker
and generally speaking i don't know how
big of a difference is but moving your
mouse but
like your physical limitation will be
like short i don't know because like i'm
thinking about like right now in my head
like if you have lower sense it takes
longer to move your mouse right this
game
will generally i think have average
higher sense of cs because of all like
the movement and stuff like
raise natural jet dash you need to like
flick um sage walls like all this like
you know like verticality and stuff but
despite the benefits of playing on high
sensitivity
not everybody agrees with it it still
has its limitations
it's really hard to be consistent on
high sense there's just some days where
you know you might hit everything and
it'll look super flashy because you have
this like ridiculous sensitivity but
uh there's just gonna be days where you
just can't hit those pixels as
consistently
and then those are the days that are
going to really stick out for you
because you know you're just getting
bodied by people holding angles and you
can't do anything about it
now true enough it can be difficult to
stay consistent when even the slightest
bit of hand movement can drastically
change your aim
but players like asuna have become
accustomed to it after
years of playing on such a high
sensitivity even in his counter-strike
days on
triumph asuna played on an equivalent
sensitivity so
like a lot of high sense converts
whether shroud or
hiko he's just used to it that said
maybe there is an answer to the mystery
of sensitivity
you just have to play on the highest
sensitivity you can control
without losing control as opposed to you
know going as low as you can
look it's simple the man is the greatest
cs go player to
ever live and he plays at a whopping
1236
edpi which is only slightly lower than
asuna's
and like 250 dpi higher than the average
cs gopro which just goes to show how
untouchably insane
some of these high sense players really
are they play with the precision and
control that comes with needing your
entire desk to move 180 degrees
while having their mouse cranked up to
move as fast as starcraft players
and contrary to popular belief you don't
need to just settle on
one sensitivity and never change it
because unless you try
other sensitivities you never know what
you might be missing
as long as you don't go like crazy you
know what i mean like just jack it up
or like play super low you you'll most
likely be fine with whatever sense you
use
um but it is always good to experiment
because like you never know
ah dude it's fine i mean you're a filthy
casual who uses a controller but uh
tell me more about how my mouse works
all right these shoes might get awkward
oh these are good i like these yeah
these are good
start out with like hey colton hey good
morning man hey to me drinking more end
with like just fast forward 30 minutes
like well [ __ ] you
man f word [ __ ] you man halo's a [ __ ]
dead game all right
well so is counter-strike [ __ ] you